welcome to this 15-minute game playing
fitness only fitness only and lots of
players our this is a brand new account
brand new account let's see a KD 6 yeah
I don't really like c-45 so quite a good
line for black get them Kings Indian ok
this is really my main my main weapon
here not per should be too I'd like to
get them I'd like to keep my options
open and in some cases try to go Castle
go inside ok h3 seems to seems to not be
honest some list of expected systems
gather main decision of course is
between c5a d5 c-5m going for benoni e5
for typical um Kings Indian play it's
important to know that b5 is not a
really good line here and though this is
very playable for black there's also see
takes transposing to a regular modern
jangling but i always have preferred
this he takes simply because it's one of
those lines that promise why them a long
term comfortable edge
without any big risks or problems yam in
this position black has the idea or the
possibility ideas wrong can play Bishop
h6 yes castles and then it can take only
three this is known for ages to be bad
for black and still displayed on and on
and on and on hide it quite remarkable
even within some GM games here you see
the slide plate with the pawn captures
it is especially bad very tough to 22
even to the playable position as black
okay still you need to punish it first
it's not like a habit all learned by
heart that can just them Rep reduce some
some kind of line okay there is some
various ideas queen age six maybe Queen
f8 go into f 49 h five maybe coming here
not sure of nigeria 95-92 d70
a queen f form looks like a good move
Knight h5 is a bit of an annoyance but
maybe not the end of the world Queen
edge fire could could be played
intending night g5 attending mighty form
yeah maybe do that and not lose on time
97 now I can just take the six that's a
very important point of course and why
he really only has the snide move I
don't see anything else can really
believe in nola King g7 I mean that
would be really amazing if this would be
playable
night h5 is Quinn h6 so any good here
the squeem f8 unfortunately
yeah I only see night h5 I don't see
another playable move King g7 is
probably more than one good thing to do
Nyjah 5s sir the easiest way probably
yeah well this is just tremendous
attacking position for just one porn why
does all both pieces into play the F
fried is open Black has played g6
weakened himself with exchanging the
dark squared bishop then 20 on the rook
on a eight night on b8 bishop on c8 are
not playing and quite often well they
won't ever play in this this line yeah I
really don't understand when I days
Shrivers okay yeah okay you can retreat
okay let's say let's see night good
tonight Queen age six looks looks
dangerous should I go for that
mine ig5 it's a very young very obvious
way to do it but probably not a bad way
rookie one that's also good but ok come
on the Queen should be really good on
age six want to move like f6 I can still
play now g5 as f 2 x g5 this rook of a
check made and i'll get to g5 I mean can
f5 to play f5 trying to to defend it
now maybe f5 is though maybe it's a five
is the toughest difference yeah I think
you should probably try a five min 0 or
1 move later yeah maybe I should have
played Rock a to you one now that i look
at this i think this was maybe the
better way to go at five a five looks
tough I cannot play 94 then now okay
night chief I've and then I'm
threatening 94 yeah
okay let's see what he's doing the
problem the general problem with a
position like that is that Blackie has a
really thankless task of defending this
it costs time and you're pretty much
prone to make errors with them with them
this type of defensive task I still
believe f5 should be done okay yeah
Nyjah file I can play anyway because of
this meeting thing let's do that I
thought f5 was better because it allowed
Knight f6 ok and here or i can go to e6
and this that way get get the d5 square
should i do that it's not bad
ma it's not bad but it's maybe not like
winning just make any sense play 94 here
maybe yea maybe then he can really take
it the night I mean ok I'll go here it
gives them in the c6 square for the
night which is not ideal really
okay 9 35 year hard to imagine that
there is something better maybe Bishop
b4 to d5 okay but this looks just like
the way to go and um no use in spending
ages on it yeah but no I'm i can start
to do very very concrete things e 7 and
drew f6 this kind of moves
is seven idea e seven rookies seven look
f6 breaking through looks looks quite
quite tough to defend okay I'm okay
didn't even consider the roof which
looked like they only move really look
f6 now i cannot even take the rook rook
fh checkmate and it's a yeah that's it
really how does it prevent rook a faint
made my rookie seven was the only move
clearly well maybe I could have taken
with the night then actually and on that
takes not X cookie one check okay where
we can look at this in the analysis as
I'm pretty much expecting resignation
now I don't see how he prevents Luke
evade okay i can sorry kind of cosmic
the night to see seven which i forgot
about
and i still have rook everyone yet it's
it's not helping much
yeah 97 look everyone why is there
something better somewhere hmm yeah it's
enough rook hof one is simply enough
after 97
I actually doubt that this was the most
efficient way to to attack probably am
the snide f queen def for Queen h6
around there there may be improvements
with f5 I think he could have put up a
stiffer resistance
I'm wondering if I'm overlooking sliding
he resigned because it took so long
running challenge I know I don't play
rematch now I need to wrap this game up
first and around here it's interesting
he may be many interesting ways to play
whether the computer likes Queen F also
not questioning that yet not too much
retreat and then it wants to play 95
though yeah that sets of course of
course also muth f6 and now the computer
gives rook a 2d one which you can only
shake your head about I know it searches
to g4 okay which at least at some point
yeah why probably has an attack in many
ways this is not bad i think but this
already thought open I really thought
that you should do a5 p.m. wow the
computer is giving g4 with a complete
win this I wouldn't have played most
likely not I mean once you see it you
pretty much instantly recognize that
this is very dangerous of course oh this
is this is entirely entirely impossible
and it really that is to take on f5 king
edge one Luke g1 and blacks like it's
totally totally busted you he's playing
without all those pieces and this means
something wow so this is very strong and
TM or the computer wants to go here
directly sacrificing okay
yeah this is in fact this is actually
what I suspected that this is not
cleared all the computers giving this is
about equal yeah I had I adhere this is
there less way for improvement maybe
this night eh form still curious about
about the situation here yeah well II
seven assists couldn't he needs to take
of course he needs to take this is this
is losing do to em group f6 so look
takes the computer here wants to take
and play rookie one with a pretty
substantial edge um I was wondering
about Luke f6 yeah if this is maybe a
move it looks it looks dangerous I don't
know the computer gives it as a winner
forward okay so I had the right hun Chea
that it should be good but it's still
very tricky of course we have the same
business yet again the question is what
happens after the capture check and now
yeah well this is something that I saw
but I wasn't sure about it looks a bit
strange all those pieces here but it
seems to be good for white I
breakthrough and this I wasn't sure
about but there seems to be a forced
made now of course there is a meta and
chanta here check check check mate okay
so many cool attacking lines this also
means that this this night before mrs.
press giving away the game s we're
really often the case nine seconds in
such a complicated position very often
the case I actually expected this smooth
without calculating it so much it just
looks good to put it in the center and
cover some
squares question is the same thing
possible probably not but I'm not sure
this is pretty much the same and winds
like can of course take check I can do
that which is not terrible getting the
bishop here and or black black as two
pawns for the exchange which is plenty
yeah very unclear but this is some this
is how really winning okay what I need
to take a load off really enter this is
very very nice is this move here really
sometimes you don't think about
especially if you don't have the time if
you have time on your hands you can find
many good things but a little time I
mean it's sometimes difficult to make
such a move in front of your own king
which tells up Lex in this case blacks
Kings position and you sort of quite
often a hesitant to think about those
moves even and the computer of course
knows no prejudice it just calculates
and once you see it like here the
solution here you you immediately almost
immediately recognize how strong it is
but to have the general idea it's not
easy as you saw in the game I didn't
think of it I was expecting f5 but I
didn't really consider g4 has been a
very serious option okay interesting
game thanks for watching